hey this is dr. Berg again in this short
beauty we're going to talk about calcium
and osteoporosis this is the loss of
bone and there's another condition
called osteopenia which is the kind of
the precursor or the thing that happens
just before osteoporosis there is a myth
going around that women get osteoporosis
because they're lacking calcium well the
the big huge trials that were just done
the research on women that take calcium
just found out that the more calcium
they take the more they get heart
attacks especially if they're
postmenopausal and I'm going to cover
why that is but most osteoporosis is not
a calcium problem per se it is a problem
with cortisol cortisol is a stress
hormone that is made by your adrenal
glands and if your adrenal glands are
overactive and the way that you become
overactive is is especially during
menopause because the adrenals back up
the ovaries during menopause because
they make estrogen so yes estrogen can
affect osteoporosis but just the fact
that the adrenals can't make up the
difference from what the ovary up when
the ovary was producing before so we
have these weak adrenals you go through
menopause and then you lose your bones
it's not because you're not eating
enough calcium it's because the high
cortisol because the three nails are so
tired they're failing to back up the
ovaries okay now what happens is when
you have high cortisol it's very
destructive on the protein in the bone
so you lose protein most of your bonus
protein and it's very destructive on
calcium as well so you lose calcium lose
protein lose other minerals and you lose
your vitamin D levels I would say most
of the vitamin D deficiencies in the
United States especially in the northern
version because they don't have as much
Sun is adrenal high cortisol that's why
we become low low in vitamin D okay
alright so cortisol that's really what's
underneath this osteoporosis so this
comes down to
stress stress will cause high cortisol
so I'm not saying live on I go live on a
desert island by yourself I'm just
saying instead of taking calcium start
do things to start to improve the stress
situation change your environment do
things that are less stressful work on
your adrenals nutritionally acupressure
go for long walks there's a lot of
things you can do for to lower cortisol
so it's rarely a calcium problem
directly studies have shown that higher
calcium and I will put the studies below
so you can look them up yourselves and
just realize I'm not making this up high
high levels of calcium will double the
chance of getting a heart attack and why
is that why because when you take
calcium calcium needs a transporter
vitamin there are two transporter
vitamins ones vitamin D which transports
the calcium into the blood but there's
another vitamin called vitamin k2 that
transports calcium from the blood all
the way into the tissues the function of
vitamin k2 is to mobilize the calcium
out of the arteries and on the soft
tissue and put it in the bone vitamin k2
is in a lot of the fats it's in
grass-fed butter it's in egg yolks it's
in goose liver it's in all the things
that the doctors tell you not to consume
if you have a heart problem right well
we need k2 you can get this in a tablet
form take a hundred micrograms and you
can then also take vitamin d3 I would
take ten thousand international units
together these two together with a
little fish oil may be cod liver oil so
if you took all three these together
this would be very very beneficial to
protect your bones why because this is
going to transport it this will help to
transport it as well and then of course
I'm not telling you not to neglect
cortisol fix this too but these are very
good protective vitamins to help
transport calcium the other thing is
just by lowering cortisol your vitamin
d3 will go up as well but this is very
beneficial now if you already have
osteoporosis you're going to need to
take some calcium I do not recommend
taking calcium carbonate if you've been
taking calcium go get your bottle right
now and look at the label make sure it's
not calcium carbonate that's limestone
you'd be better off chewing on the
cement outside it's just rocks it's not
going to absorb you need calcium citrate
calcium lactate calcium gluconate all
the different types of calcium but not
carbonate but if you have osteoporosis
you might want to add calcium to this
and that would be your like your your
bone building factors and to prevent the
heart attacks the last point I wanted to
make is that is this many people ask me
like what food can I can I get these
vitamins it's very difficult to get
vitamin D from food unless you consume
cod liver oil but you can get it from
the Sun so if you go outside ten minutes
a day or 15 you can get 10,000 IU's so
that way it's it's free you don't to
take it okay but definitely the k2
that's the one that you want to take
more of to help prevent this and then
again check with your doctor if you have
this I'm not telling you that this is
going to cure your diagnosed this is the
reason why you have osteoporosis but I'm
just giving you some extra data to
present to your doctor so you guys can
figure it out but it takes if you have
osteoporosis it does take a bit of time
to have that be restored it could take
several years because it's a really a
major problem in the body when you have
osteoporosis your body has been very
very very health wise been way way down
so give it time it's not going to come
back in two months it's going to take
probably yours but this will help you
hope you enjoy the video I'll see you in
the next one